we're taking calls via Discord just as a
reminder to everybody waiting to chat
with me if you actually want the
opportunity to talk
your nickname in the waiting Lobby on
Discord needs to be your name and where
you're calling from or where you're
calling from and your name a lot of
people with nicknames are not going to
get called on okay just as just as a
heads up so everybody understands that
let's go next to Tristan from Boston
Tristan welcome
hey David what's up how are you
I'm feeling okay good so
um
my question would be you remember a
while back the uh
detective work by
that American muckrakers pack is what
ended up getting uh Madison cawthorne
fired
well yeah I mean I don't know that
cawthorne lost only because of the
salacious stuff released about him I
don't know but I remember the I remember
the American muckrakers pack and the
stuff that they released certainly yes
do you think we'll hear from them again
in actually succeeding in smearing
someone enough to get them out of
Congress so I don't remember if it was
the same people who tried with Lauren
bobert and it didn't go anywhere because
it wasn't very well sourced or if that
was a different organization I just
don't remember offhand but it's sort of
a question about a prediction I have no
idea I don't know if they have dirt on
someone else but it's certainly
conceivable that we would
the site fire bobert is still up and I
assume it will be up
for as long as it takes for her to
leave Congress
all right well we will keep an eye on it
other than that the
their site right now is just a bunch of
criminal Republicans not looking so
caught in uh not so hot poses
fair so I guess that's what the best we
can hope for for now
all right Tristan very good we'll keep
an eye on it
cool thanks all right Tristan from
Boston with a very important declaration
let's go next to Philip from Germany
Philip welcome
hello hello uh can you hear me well so I
can hear you there is a static hiss in
the background whenever you talk
okay I don't really know why but my main
question is that basically back in the
times of the Civil War the rules of the
Democratic and Republican party were
kind of reversed where the Democrats
were the one with with the slaves and
Abraham Lincoln was from the Republicans
we're freeing the slaves and so on and
nowadays well it's all kind in Reverse
especially when you have Confederate
flags being waived at January 6 and all
that and you have an idea how that
reversal came to be yeah there's
actually been multiple reversals and I
think that you know this can be very
confusing even to Americans so my advice
on this issue is to think about it in
the following way
the right wing
was in favor of owning slaves and the
party name that was the a correct name
at the time is less relevant than the
fact that it was the political right
that wanted the slaves and the political
quite frankly Center and left and even
to some degree center right that did not
and that makes it so you don't have to
remember when the party realignments
took place
okay but still kind of weird that the
Republicans were Center or or perhaps
even Center left not sure well remember
not all Republicans Republican not all
of Lincoln's Republicans wanted to end
slavery that's that's Lincoln did but
not the entire Republican party did not
want to
also interesting I guess but yeah it
kind of happens to go that way that
basically the Democrats were were
hardlined into slaves and yeah Lincoln's
Direction was yeah against this yeah I
would even want to double check that
because I don't even know for sure that
that it's that Democrats were into
slaves let me double check because there
were multiple parties at the time but
I'm gonna let you go because that
hissing is just so bad okay
oh sorry okay no problem no problem all
right good we'll get that figured out
for next time but that is that is quite
an audio element that was taking place
there